amy is with us in California hi Amy
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thank you so much for taking my call I
feel really honored to be talking to you
you too thank you I have a question
about my husband's employee stock
purchase plan
he works I said at home with the kids
his employee stock purchase plan works
to my knowledge where we've we put aside
money each paycheck he currently makes
or I'm sorry $200,000 a year so we're
putting aside each paycheck $1,000 into
this employee stock purchase plans each
every six months were able to cash it
out and buy our stock for at least 15%
under the market value so in every six
months we cash it out immediately and
toss it out so anyway my direct question
is with our with our monthly budget we
go or is read without that extra $3,000
a month I mean that really puts a huge
$10,000 a year and you're in the red
without that extra $2,000 gosh really I
mean okay so we just started our budget
plan with you last month we're really
gung-ho we're excited about it but you
know we overbought on our house living
here I'm gonna let you know how much is
your house payment like two thousand
seven hundred sixty dollars a month
that's not your problem
because you're tired your take-home pay
should be $10,000 a month or more how
much is he putting money in a 401k also
he is he's putting in fifteen precise
and how much of your income is going
into cars
we actually just last month since we
started it we just paid off our car
another car payment no we're done with
our cars we only have two more credit
card bills to pay off that amount to six
thousand $179
okay so $10,000 take-home pay it should
know not with 15% and $2,000 coming out
that's not you're not getting home with
about about 6,000 are you know yeah sure
that's that's where is that something
right six thousand a month coming in yes
that's exactly it yeah so each month
yeah six thousand two hundred ninety
dollars okay I've got it pretty close
all right well let's go back and talk
about two or three things number one
there's not room in your budget for the
stock purchase okay you knew that before
you called me you know I did and that's
not the problem is they keep talking my
husband not in well you don't have to
talk to him about it you just tell them
there's not room in the budget we don't
make enough money for you to put two
thousand dollars a month in the stock
number two I wouldn't do it anyway even
if you had the money and here's why okay
there's nothing special about this stock
purchase plan all employee stock
purchase plans are 15% off all of them
are everybody does that that's a
publicly traded company and allows their
company their employees to buy their
stock okay there's nothing special about
that here's the other thing single
stocks are very volatile it's a very
risky investment even if it's the
company he works for that he feels like
he knows something about okay and here's
the thing if you don't believe me just
pull up that company you notice I don't
even know who it is yet okay pull up no
I believe you know pull up that company
on the internet and pull up their stock
just type in such as such stock okay and
I make at the 52-week high and the
52-week low in other words in one year
how much volatility does it have and you
will see a swing of greater than 15% so
it is entirely possible you lose money
on this transaction before you even make
the transaction okay and even if you
don't even if you don't shortly after
you could lose it now it may shoot way
up in value it makes you way down in
value I don't know I I have tens of
millions of dollars invested in the
stock market and mutual funds
and have none of it not one penny of it
in single stock and even if you can cash
it out right away
you still advise against it even though
it's the 15% discount yeah because
you're not necessarily even going to
make that okay you know and so I'm just
not this is not worth messing with and
so you're better off to do some other
stuff with your money
like for instance bring at home so that
you're not in the red which is
absolutely crazy but but you make
$200,000 a year and you're getting home
with 72,000 you got that that's nuts
okay so turns out yeah 15% going into
retirement would be thirty thousand of
your two hundred thousand you got taxes
coming out as he bought a bunch of other
stuff and his employee benefits package
that he pays for we have let's see I'm
sorry we have health benefits like any
other person no you're paying for health
insurance correct yes we paying for
health insurance as well that's probably
a thousand a month right at least
because we have three kids you know
that's another 12,000 a year so 42,000
has health insurance and 15% going into
retirement out of your 200 and we could
just kind of get back down I want I just
want you to understand you're trying to
run your household on 72,000 that's six
thousand dollars a month when you
started with two hundred at the top
there's something I know this is why
well we're kind of sick yeah gap there
some of that's taxes and you do live in
California so you got to double dip on
the taxes again a real high tax rate and
but you got you know federal income
taxes a bunch on this so all of that's
mixed into this equation but yeah I
wouldn't fool with it because of single
stocks
I wouldn't feel with it because 15
percent is not enough of a gap to fool
with I wouldn't fool with it because
you're in the red first and foremost and
I hope that helps you thanks for the
call